You can sense that.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I remember the first time I met,
Meryl Streep was at this theater that I
told you about,
the Phoenix theater.
And she walked in and she had her pants
old tied up because she was riding a
bike to the audition and she had a wheel
or wheel of her pain in her hands and
her hair was all messy.
And I thought,
oh my God,
she's glorious.
She is.
She's just beautiful.
And,
um,
so you do get those feelings.
You Do,
you are drawn to people that,
you know,
come in,
come sit down next to you and talk to
you and you see something,
maybe they're not necessarily right for
the park,
but there's something about their
personalities.
Maybe you want to put them in another
role.
Um,
but yes,
the room changes,
the color changes.
Usually golden golden,
golden yellow I think is for me.
And I get very excited and you know,
and,
and try to place these performers in,
in,
um,
in either the role that they've come in
for,
or in another part,
I like to think that when I cast or
movie
or even working on a movie,
that it would be a movie that people
will see a hundred years from now.
I think that's what I always look at
things like,
will people look at this project,
this movie,
this actor,
and a hundred years in the same way we
look at,
uh,
Betty Davis and,
and,
and cary grant and Humphrey Bogart.
And,
and
I think we were looking at them for a
very long time.
I think that's the,
the,
the goal to see that talent that you
think will last forever and ever and
ever.